welcome back to new rock stars the
falcon in the winter soldier is dragging
us once again down the one division
rabbit hole with the promise
of a mystery character coming in episode
five
who apparently would be a great thor
partner no
it's not mephisto shut up but we will we
will take this bait nonetheless
because that's what we do here i'm eric
boss this is rogue theory with me
today is an amazing panel i'm so excited
to talk with them
uh starting with the co-host of our
falcon winter soldier after show mt
hello everybody it's good to be back i
love talking
nerd with you guys yes us too and also
friend of the show comedian danielle
spiso
hi guys hey danielle welcome back
and we are so happy to welcome to new
rock stars from gamertag radio and the
kind of funny family the network
paris lily welcome man oh thank you so
much for having me i
i am i'm honored to be here and very
excited to talk about some falcon and
winter soldier oh yeah we're gonna do it
uh so here we go our first topic the
falcon the winter soldier creator
malcolm spellman told rotten tomatoes tv
host
jacqueline coley that a new character is
coming in episode 5
whom he would love to see paired with
thor roll that clip josh
there are characters in our series
who uh uh who i would love
to see partnered with like that's it's a
very very grounded character
partnered with one of the big uh what
are they calling the world shakers you
know i'm saying like thor
or someone like that you know i'm saying
who hasn't moved on because
the personality is so strong it's the
episode five character
i'd love to see that character with thor
we got another mystery cameo folks
didn't he also say it's gonna make you
cry
wasn't that part of it too what like
later on didn't he say something
like it's like a tear-jerker didn't he
say something like that i do vaguely
remember that i didn't immediately
connect that with this character but i
think you may be right
yeah you said episode five it's a big
one
it's gonna make you cry dang so
there's a lot to break down here uh now
sure we did
learn our lesson in one division that
you can't really trust the hype when it
comes from the cast
we're looking at you paul bettany yes
directly at you into your pupils
exactly but in this case malcolm
spellman is a head writer he created
this show
and he really did intentionally temper
expectations
with his tease he was being specific
like he gave us these qualities right
a very very grounded character uh the
personality is so strong
and uh apparently also someone who might
have an emotional
uh connection with us i mean after paul
bettany i wouldn't be surprised if it
was like a golden retriever puppy
[Laughter]
like it's the dog from marley and me
it's a small make me cry
super grounded let's let's try to narrow
this down really we're looking for
a grounded strong-willed personality
that would make them kind of a fun
partner maybe a contrast or maybe
someone like-minded
to the over-the-top norse demi-god thor
uh and let's remember folks this is a
series about super soldiers post-blip
social realities america's dark history
with human testing
so rather than going rogue with marvel
demons or cosmic
space gods let's go down uh the rabbit
hole
roguely of malcolm spellman's
imagination what earthling do we think
he was referring to who would make the
best
partner to thor am i crazy just totally
crazy for wanting it to be old cat
like is that just totally out of the
question
like am i just setting myself up for
disappointment for thinking that that
could possibly be
it i don't think so i think you are
unfortunately
as much as i would love it that would be
amazing seeing old thor
and like you know just young i mean old
cap and young thor
just like hanging out and like it'd be
amazing well again i go
i got to go back to what what eric said
one division has taught me
to set expectations accordingly so
my wacky theory on this is actually goes
with kind of the complete opposite of
what you would think would pair with
thor
so this show clearly obviously is about
falcon and his journey to become captain
america right
but there's a subplot in here that i
think they're building to
and that is thaddeus thunderbolt ross
aka the thunderbolts i really think
we're we're building towards that we
know zemo's coming
in the next episode he leads to
thunderbolts who's one of his first
recruits
it's eric johnston aka atlas
so with the whole super soldier program
we know this is about
super soldiers and creating them we know
thunderbolt ross
looms large over this entire series you
know with the super soldier program
so what better way to introduce a brand
new character
who would have a a strong enough power
set
that he could hang with thor you make it
one of the thunderbolts so so that's my
wacky one
i'll also jump in really quick and say i
have a far-fetched one which i'm pretty
sure won't happen
but we know that emil blonsky
aka the abomination is going to return
in she-hulk
what's to say he does not return here
in a surprise because once again he is
tied to thunderbolt ross and he is also
tied to the super soldier program so
what better way to bring abomination in
than bucky and falcon
go talk to blonsky about the super
soldier serum so here we go
yeah and like you got to think not only
is he tied to the super soldier history
he is that kind of strong-willed uh
personality who
you know he you could totally see uh uh
tim roth
like having fireworks with uh with thor
in a scene right like
oh you think you're the great warrior
taryn you know
he's like i fall to hulk too
[Laughter]
i i'm gonna go with something a little
bit wild and
it's not definitely not as grounded but
i honestly think that it could
potentially be our old boy hercules and
this is a character that i've been
wanting in the mcu
for such a long time because marvel um
hercules
and thor do go at it from time to time
but like
in a brotherly type of way and like they
have a really good
relationship in the comics so i mean
who's to say
that maybe these super soldiers got
their powers from
i don't know hercules experimentation
who knows
it's just it could be anything but i
really would love to see
hercules um just come out of left field
and be like hello
i'm here now um i'll see you later in a
future marvel project
but i i'm all about hercules having
another mythological god come in or it's
hercules isn't god he's son of a god
right he's like a demigod type deal
as long as it's not played by kevin
sorbo i'm down yeah
yeah uh that's an interesting idea too i
mean just to remind everyone of who we
already know or who already has shown up
we know uh roadie made his cameo bad
truck and then we just saw isaiah
bradley and his grandson eli bradley
zemo's coming next episode sharon
carter's coming up some mysterious power
broker figures in the shadows and
thaddeus ross has been teased in the in
the credits um
now there have been a bunch of theories
that have been out there on top of what
we've talked about here and
there's uh there's been this kind of
long-running theory that there's going
to be a crossover
between falcon and the winter soldier
and black widow so i'm wondering if this
character could be someone
like whoever taskmaster ends up being
could be this person and you just
imagine like taskmaster is someone who
mirrors
everybody and could have like kind of a
fun back and forth with thor
of like he knows all of thor's moves and
there was like how can i not strike you
and he just blocks everything it just
depends on who tasman i think they're
gonna keep that
taskmaster reveal for the black widow
movie but like you know we do have elena
bulova
ot peg ben lei's playing uh this uh rick
mason character david harper's playing
red guardian
i wonder if one of these faces could
show up in the show uh that'd be kind of
fun
i would love to see red guardian okay oh
my god oh yeah it'll be so good i
honestly now that you bring that up if
red guardian survives black widow which
i don't believe that he will
he's it's looking not good for red
guardian um
for me anyway but if he does survive
black widow oh man him and thor would
kill it together it would be so good
oh yeah that would be really good that
chemistry would be hilarious
and again i've learned to not expect too
much
but um we know that it met madrid madrid
oh i'm saying the name wrong the the
island the mutant island
magic there thank you yeah um there has
been rumors about potentially omega red
showing up in this and oh that would be
perfect with thor that would be another
great pairing but
i am not holding my breath for any
mutant ex-gene personality showing up
in this show i mean do you think it has
to be an introduction of our whole new
character or
going with the bradley family like eli
bradley coming into his
like super soldier new avengers
character we've already been introduced
to him in the show
but i could see a chain of events that
like him taking his power
whether that's like i read something
like blood transfusion from his
grandfather because he's so brutally
hurt
or he gets you know the super soldier
serum somehow
and is introduced as a new super soldier
character as opposed to just
you know regular old grandson you make a
good point on that because if it's
someone that we've already been
introduced to but now he becomes the
quote-unquote
superhero character that we're expecting
i guess the tragedy the emotional of
this would be isaiah bradley potentially
passing away somehow and that could be
the catalyst to
kick uh kick him off into one what was
it patriot is his younger avengers name
i believe or something like that yeah
and that's the teardriver moment
everyone's looking for i could see that
as a tearjerker moment i mean eli
bradley has an interesting character arc
where he seems to have uh super soldier
abilities but then he was just juicing
up on that mutant growth hormone
and the rest of the young adventurers
had to be like no we still value you as
a team member
and a human being and then he kind of
stays on as like fine i'm gonna have the
tactics and the strategy and i'm gonna
call the shots
um any but that's a whole arc where he
has to learn to like he doesn't have to
be
you know super uh agility and super
strong
it's really a message for the kids okay
[Laughter]
but here's an idea um because um
or turtles was supposed to be out by now
but before we'll fall in the winter
soldier right
so like what if we're talking about an
eternals character that we haven't seen
yet because the movie's not
yeah there's there's like two questions
that are kind of when it comes to this
uh spelman quote like
how much how sincere was he when he said
uh
it's a very very grounded character was
he backpedaling in that moment
i don't know he was trying to say like a
contrast with the world breaker he's
like defining new terms like this is
what a world breaker is or a world
shatter
um uh and then the second question is
like as we saw with one division
you know it's really hard to keep like a
big name
off of the like we just saw with thor
love and thunder
uh russell crowe was supposed to be kept
a secret and then it got out
and and we saw it with evan peters too
so it's kind of hard if it's a huge huge
name
someone's gonna talk wait time out eric
you said
you said the word grounded and that got
me thinking what if
you know who's the ground the most
groundedest character of all in marvel
history
mo man what if we're talking about a
moment no i'm just kidding
that's 100 but i hope it's that'd be
hilarious if it wasn't
for adventures i'd give them 100 per
ticket multiple times
um all right all three of you guys had
some great takes there even though this
is a new version of rogue theory where
we're just talking we're just talking
i'm still insane and i still mentally
award points
according to some algorithm that you
know i i don't tell people about
but it does uh print out in the form of
these gold and sparkle books
uh i won't tell you from where it just
prints out and
prints out unlimited supply so let's see
uh you guys all want some good theories
i'm gonna award one
sparkle book to danielle i really like
this idea i don't think it's wrong to
hold on to hope for old cap to
right i think they'd be yeah they'd be
good buddies to see those two together
ultimate tearjerker movement mt you're
also getting
uh a point there for this hercules idea
oh thank you yeah it was that super
strength maybe the original
uh super soldier that mystery cocktail
that erskine had back in the day was
a stride from hercules dna who knows
me um but uh paris i'm gonna give you
two points just because i think both
your pitches
of it being either atlas or uh
or what was the other one you said you
said abomination miel blonsky
abomination
uh yeah blonsky and yeah both of those
i'm like yeah those both make sense to
me i would love those so you get two
points
well i like atlas and abomination were
two very good ideas
i didn't think about both of those well
honestly again i blame wanda vision
because my theories were so far out
there you thought galactus was about to
show up
in that show so i'm like okay let's keep
this as grounded as we possibly can and
it would just make sense the way that
the series is going to see a character
like that we all got
burned by one division and like it's
really because
juan division people are like well it's
not every marvel show the falcon of the
winter soldier i don't think is gonna
mephisto because it's a show that is
super grounded whereas one division
dipped just enough into the supernatural
into the cosmic
to make us believe that anything could
be possible you know
well we're moving on together first i
want to talk about some people helped us
make this episode thank you to our
friends at expressvpn
so most of us have a really very little
choice over an internet service provider
because isps
operate kind of like monopolies in the
regions they serve they use this
monopoly power to take advantage of
customers
data caps streaming throttles the list
goes on and on but they also log your
internet activity and they sell that
data to other big tech companies or
advertisers
so to prevent isps from seeing my
internet activity i protect my devices
with
expressvpn it's really a simple app for
your computer or smartphone that
encrypts all of your network data and
then tunnels it
through a secure vpn server so that your
isp cannot see any of your activity
i recommend expressvpn as the best way
to hide your online activity from your
isp
just download the app tap one button on
your device and you are protected
and expressvpn does all of this without
slowing your connection
that's why it's rated the number one vpn
service by cnet and wired
so stop handing over your personal data
to isps and other big tech giants
who mine your activity and sell off your
information protect yourself with the
vpn i trust to
help me keep private online visit
expressvpn.com
rogue that's expressvpn.comrogue to get
three
extra months for free go to
expressvpn.com right now to learn more
all right we also want to thank our
friends at caliber cbd so
who says taking care of yourself needs
to be hard what's great about uh
cbd is that it helps you feel better
without making drastic changes to your
routine
it's been a help for me when sleeping
and soreness especially since you know
i've been doing this whole fitness
challenge
my body's doing things that it does not
want to do and probably won't do after
this challenge is over
so just to get me through these hellish
12 weeks
it's great to have little helps like
this uh actually this past january
colorado state university published the
first ever peer-reviewed study to
compare
how different cbd products on the market
are absorbed and processed by the body
caliper cbd was found to deliver 30
times more cbd than cbd oil in the first
30 minutes
caliper gives you all the benefits of
cbd in just 10 minutes
cbd oils could take up to two hours to
fully absorb which is way longer than
you really want to wait
and the great thing about calipers
little powder packets is that they're
mobile so you can take them to work or
on the road just pop one in your morning
tea or afternoon smoothie
and you can get 20 off your first order
would use the promo code rogue at
tricaliper.com rogue you can try caliper
cbd risk-free for 30 days and if you
don't love it they'll give you a full
refund that's tricaliper.com don't
forget to use the promo code rogue for
20
off your first order all right let's
move right along to some other big news
we just got this week
the cast for the obi-wan kenobi series
the disney plus was announced
so uh there was this amazing graphic uh
show that graphic josh josh is like
i enough i've had to do too much editing
so uh we already knew you mcgregor was
gonna come back as obi-wan and they
announced last december that hayden
christensen is going to return as darth
vader which is
amazing uh but beyond those two we got
moses ingram
in a mystery role she actually said she
would get to play with lightsabers
that's interesting
um joel edgerton is coming back as uncle
owen lars and bonnie psc
aka the nexium escapee from the hbo
documentary escaped
for this yeah she got away uh she's
coming back as uh aunt peru
uh they're both coming back from revenge
of the sith that final scene
and uh in various unknown roles camille
non-gianni this guy's
getting work um get it and we got
indira varma you may know her as uh
lauri ellaria sand from game of thrones
uh rupert friend i know him from
homeland uh o'shea jackson jr
is in this yes yes uh sung kang
han from curious han lives
a different han in this universe uh and
then we got simone kessel
and uh benny safty aka the co-director
of uncut gems this guy does it all
wow so this series will be set 10 years
after order 66 and revenge of the sith
where uh anakin or is vader
at that point and obi-wan had their epic
duel and then this is gonna be nine
years before
obi-wan meets young luke skywalker in
star wars a new hope so during this
obi-wan series luke's gonna be about 10
years old
uh so for you guys knowing this is the
cast what do you think the series is
gonna be about
like the mandalorian's mission was to
protect the child baby yoda grogu
uh what will obi-wan's mission be in
this series
kicking it in tatooine hope to god that
we're not just in tattoo weed i hope we
go to other planets because
it's just so like just dry it just
smells
very deserty and like not that
interesting
yeah yeah tatooine is obviously going to
be i think the thing that excites me the
most about this series is
obviously it's it's obi-wan we're
getting more more of that and his story
what he's been up to but i look at it in
the way that we're going to see
darth vader in his literal prime being
10 years after the events
of this and it's pretty clear they're
going to have one more confrontation so
this now takes that line in a new hope
and gives a completely new meaning where
he says the last
i left you i was a student but you know
now i am the master so
what does that mean what does that
confrontation look like what is
the the the struggle that
anakin or darth vader is going through
in this series because
you know he he lost a love of his life
he he assumes
that the unborn child is lost as well
he's now
half man half machine yeah he's serving
palpatine he's on the dark side
so is there a struggle there that
there's there a side of vader that we
never got to see you know in the
original
uh trilogy that they can now put on
display here
and then the backdrop of that we're
getting the avenger the avengers the
adventures
of uh obi-wan kenobi and what does that
mean being a protector
of luke skywalker crossover yeah there
you go
but no i really like that you brought
that up because the darth in the darth
vader comics
we see darth vader become darth vader
slowly like we see the beginnings of his
career
and those comics are amazing anybody
watching this video right now
go read the darth vader comics because
good god like it is
fantastic so being able to see darth
vader in his prime
we're gonna see some crazy [ __ ] we're
gonna see some real crazy [ __ ]
but also to your other point about you
know you're totally right because like
he
is you know he has a struggle going on
and with him being palpatine's new
apprentice and
you know palpatine wanting him to you
know sort of
you know control himself and become this
ruthless man
it's going to be interesting to see his
humanity slowly
die off over you know within this period
of him being
you know this new apprentice so yeah no
you're totally right i do love that
well that's why i wonder if there's
going to be any sort of use of like
flashbacks at all because otherwise
hayden christensen better be working on
his james earl jones impression
because what are we gonna see of him
like he's
he wears his helmet all the time you
know right like in this
period he's disfigured and and
you know doesn't want to take off his or
can't really you know and so right
i'm interested to see like where hayden
christensen is
coming in to this as far as an
actor like unless we see like flashback
kind of stuff
or you're right you're totally right and
then they could just hire anybody
to be a guy in a suit why hayden so i'm
thinking there's like two ways there's
either like tony stark helmet
uh cam you know where it's like inside
the helmet it's just hayden's in a dark
room essentially
but he's like at least i'll burn or like
it could be like a forced meditation
thing
like you see vader walk around but
himself
yeah i mean we're only talking about
like six episodes i think it's a mini
series so if it's just like he has a big
role but like as he's having some kind
of
psychic battle with uh with obi-wan
kenobi
but like they're connecting in some kind
of force metaphysical space
you know all i'm really hoping for is a
little bit of liam neeson
force uh
[Music]
like i feel like he's such a huge part
of obi-wan's
journey and development that like how
could he not
play a part in like force ghost style
obviously
but i feel like he has to play a part in
these like formative years before he
meets luke
i mean there's also another character
that could
potentially pop up in here and uh
obi-wan could have one more
confrontation with him as well
you know what i'm going to say
absolutely darth maul yeah yeah i mean
it it lines up even if you go by solo
which
is at the same time i can't remember the
timeline of solo if it's around the same
time
this is happening but we know darth maul
is out there we know he's being active
so
that could also be something that we see
obi-wan uh tackling through
through the six episodes god yeah so god
i hope so yeah
well they had that great reunion in uh
rebels right in the
in the you know god how bad yeah they
have that great tool
oh it was so amazing so to have like
another moment where they crossed paths
or nearly crossed paths would be really
fun
uh i'm just wondering if like if you
have uh moses ingram
is like this lightsaber user is there
like
maybe some other jedi escapees from the
jedi temple after ordering success
i think so and yeah vader's hunting them
down with the inquisitors or something
like that and then
obi-wan has to help them escape maybe
well i mean you because if you think
about it from from a
a a timeline perspective darth vader
would
system because remember obi-wan even
says that to luke that darth vader
systematically hunt down and destroy the
jedi so
he would probably be continuing to do
that even 10 years later trying to take
out the stragglers
so yeah yeah absolutely we'd see that
yeah and like you gotta think about like
you know the guilt that obi-wan kenobi
feels
with you know failing to kill darth
vader who is now
killing all of these people so i feel
like a good thing in this um
of a big story point in obi-wan's show
is seeing him deal with that guilt and
possibly
trying to correct his mistake with
trying to kill darth vader i'm also like
excited to hear that like
uncle and aunt beru are going to be here
which skywalker will at least be seen
from a distance
i wonder if there's some kind of plot
like uh luke skywalker's
location gets discovered and that
obi-wan is to keep that information kind
of like a reverse death star
battle plans get now like he has to
chase down someone with like
the disc or whatever that says this is
where this kid is
and before that information get back to
the empire
obi-wan has to like gun that person down
or yeah because i mean i
i i also think with that i i thought a
lot a lot about that relationship
because when we see them in the new hope
it is very clear that uncle owen does
not like
ben kenobi yeah so you have to think if
you go by the end of episode three
there was probably a relationship there
and something happens to absolutely sour
it
i don't want want anything to do with
you anymore stay away from the boy we
don't want violence
and now you know ben's off in the woods
or in a cave or wherever he was
right you know so i i do think we'll see
that relationship explored too
i noticed they haven't cast 10 year old
luke yet and i just wanted to put it out
there
i am available
like musical peter pan style like you
know what i support this let's let's get
a hashtag going
i support you i'm
[Laughter]
uh well some great points there across
the board
uh i loved all your theories um this
idea of the
the leonis and qui-gon gin cameo
danielle you get the point there
great because he was like one of the
people who
correct me if i'm wrong wasn't he one of
the early force ghost uh
practitioners like he was one of the
first jedi to talk about that obi wan
how to do the force ghost thing didn't
he teach yoda too
wasn't that i think yes
right yeah obi-wan i've been i've been
stalking his interviews and he has says
he hasn't been approached yet
so or in the last interview but you know
maybe
he's really good at keeping things under
wraps exactly i mean ob
i mean an obi-wan his name is not even
mcgregor
um said that he had to lie for like what
four years about his uh
about the obi-wan series that's true
yeah um okay well uh we have one final
round of just one road question that all
of you guys uh can answer
um so for this one it's a tokyo a tokyo
man was arrested for scaling a six-story
building to steal
ten thousand dollars worth of pokemon
and yu-gi-oh cards
so the question is what nerdy
collectibles would you be willing to
climb a building for
oh that's a good one you know i really
thought
that my collection would come make me a
millionaire one day and it hasn't really
panned out like i thought
but some og beanie babies i think they
have their time
they're gonna be worth a lot one day oh
yeah for sure and so
you know with the with the tag
protectors on them
that's right yeah oh yeah you got to
have those on otherwise yeah you have
og like og og beanie babies yeah
not only do i have the og beanie babies
i have
when mcdonald's did mini beanie babies
in their happy meals i collected those
too
okay stop flexing on us right now
like honestly keep all of those because
those will probably be worth a lot of
money
since i was like 10 years old and
they're still holding out hope
so they're living in my closet we'll see
one day maybe
i would say for me and this is probably
showing my age at this point but
i would do anything possible scale any
wall
to go get the entire g1
collection of the transformers from the
mid-80s
right now i would just have them set up
somewhere and i would just stare at them
that's all i would do i support that
yeah if it was me
i think this is gonna be kind of weird
and then like it's gonna be showing my
my ultra nerdy side well not really but
the lost episodes of doctor who
um there are a ton of episodes from like
the back in like the day
that just no one can find so if they
were on the top of a building and i
needed to scale it instead of using the
elevator for some reason
i'm scaling that building yeah
absolutely and
probably falling off like a quarter of
the way off because i don't have good
grip strength
but uh i'm gonna try anyway for the yeah
borderline mythical uh macguffin
of the doc missing doctor who episodes
mt
i think you have to get the point thank
you michael
that's the ark of the covenant level
gotta get it
um which according to my point total
ends up with a tie
between our three panelists so we're all
winners or all losers
you take your pick this episode
congratulations everyone we're all
losers but you're all winners in my
heart this is such a fun episode of
rogue theory i've
mentally enjoyed talking with you guys
about this stuff uh so i want to thank
all three of our
our co-hosts here mt uh danielle espiso
and paris lilly follow all three of them
on all their social media support all of
their projects all three of them are
doing amazing things show them some love
and support this channel by checking out
one of our many great merch options at
nurseriesmerch.com i'm wearing our new
falcon winter soldier themed shirt
called anarchy assembled
it's really cool i love it uh and you
can get that at newarksourcemerch.com
follow me at ea boss follow me rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube
and we will see you all next time bye
[Music]
you